[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cherry et je rappelle à ton des
nouvelles d'isabelle morini bosc
c'est la grande question que vous vous
posez oui elle est toujours à fait
toujours partie des missions oui elle
habite toujours dans les environs
ira-t-elle revenir c'est la grande
question qu'on se pose voilà un espère
car dans notre coeur exactement c'est
vrai bravo mercedes light mais ça me
fait plaisir alors matthieu delormeau a
deux passions dans la vie
lui-même est l'argent hier dans
l'émission vous avez fait un jeu où il a
perdu son salaire du joueur mais c'est
vrai je le remets donc le laurier de la
meilleure tête du gars qui est dégoûté
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs vous perdez votre salaire du
jour
en plus elle est à vous aviez pas trop
donné donc ça va barder mon salaire
ouais mais bon sur les missions vous
n'étiez pas au top non plus mais ça va
d'accord donc comment tu l'as trouvé
hier au hamois lui hier un pas
maintenant oui ça fait un beau sourire
tu as triché là tu es malheureux aller
bosser et alors tous les matins je
n'aurais jamais c'est au programme sur
france 2 alors parce que j'aime en
savoir plus sur la ménopause et d'uriné
et puis dans cette émission on y apprend
aussi aux femmes à se défendre en cas
d'agression
vous allez voir que si on se fait
attaquer dans la rue pas besoin de
couteau pas besoin de mitraillettes il
suffit pour se défendre d'avoir un
exemple par exemple un stylo au magazine
ça suffit largement
il ya un comédien certains cas mix qui
est venu pour que l'agresseur et le
pauvre lui remet le loire y ait du gars
qui n'avait pas prévu d'en prendre plein
la gueule pendant 10 minutes avec alliès
du baril et âme un comédien qui
l'accompagnent alors il la compagnie va
le regretter tout de suite fait pas
vraiment qu'on peut aussi transformer un
magazine on matraque de benalla va taper
je tombe par plaisir avec
alors c'est sûr le pauvre canix il va se
faire attaquer avec un stylo monsieur
arrêtez donc ont dû planter le décor
soit le bouquet final pour le pauvre cas
merci thank you no more heroes fait mal
le meilleur c'est les commentaires et
celui d'avant oui donc là vous me
planter un stylo ne peut pas on peut
voir ou revoir le dernier que le déclin
et la lampe torche et m'a dit qu'il
regardait encore je regardais voilà il
arrive il la soulève
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce bel espace non mais t'es
exprès de tomber sans rigoler vous y
croyez à ça et lorsque arméniens mais
les mecs si franchement mathieu elle a
l'air de jeu passe de le faire soi même
avec de vrais nécessiteux
non non non c'est sylvain krav maga va
faire ça à cyril on va voir s'il est
tombé qu'en magasin si donc nous planter
dans voulez vous voulez vous attaquer
non non non avec grand plaisir
je ne voulais m'attaquer vraiment pas
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
alors alors tu vas normal parce que je
la sens extrêmement motivant je sens
très motivé comme jamais alors je crois
qu'elle a envie de vous faire mal au
niveau le point d'aller attention vous
voulez un attention quand même les
cherry on va se retrouver dans un camp
vous voulez qu'on vous défendez pas mal
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans un instant vous
allez découvrir vous connaissez les
enquêtes de babar il va y avoir le
cousin l'inspecteur la bavure
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas encore merci les marchés w9
savaient qu'ils sont toujours en asie
alors pour eux évidemment l'asie c'est
un pays mais même à dix mille kilomètres
de marseille je pense à eux en leur
remettant le laurier de ceux qui ont
taillé landes n'oublie pas de bien
représenter la langue française vingt
six mois il ya parade du beau cheval
j'ai vu des trucs louches mais
sincèrement hockey mike un centre de
mater les jeunes ne peut pas consulter
tout le monde tout le temps maybach a
franchi une ligne infranchissable ou là
moi ça me met les boules au lantus ao
vous moquer des expressions à la con et
marseille mais y en a ici niveau
expression c'est pas beaucoup mieux 17
ans le cas rien ils sont passés comme un
mouton sur le sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit
ça
[Applaudissements]
cb alors il ya des gens qui sont venus
dans la vie alors pour s'occuper et
décide de s'inscrire au marathon et il
court pendant des heures pour faire 42
km alors que sa voiture se serait plié
en 30 minutes
alors pendant le marathon de londres
dimanche il y avait un gars qui trouvait
pas assez difficile de courir pendant
quatre heures alors il a décidé de
courir déguisé en big ben
je lui remets le laurier du gars qui
s'est tapé 42 km mais qui n'avait pas
prévu le truc à la fin pendant 42 km à
combien se déguiser en big band n'a plus
qu'à passer la ligne d'arrivée est là
je veux en fait ce monsieur ça lui
arrive très souvent ça lui est arrivé
sur le plateau de thé pmp souvenez vous
[Rires]
[Musique]
bien sûr et donc on finir série damages
dessus sur vous auriez fait un très bon
flic pourquoi as tu déjà vous avez des
indics
parce qu'il vous dise racontent toutes
les histoires sur les chroniqueurs on
sait pas comment c'est possible et je
dis pas ce que vous auriez été parfait
pour faire avouer des suspects ouais je
suis nommé cécile parce que vous adorez
mentir vous pourtant vous détestez quand
vous mentent
si si si si si comme ce jour où votre
suspecte se nomme francesca antoniotti
ah oui vous avez la cuisine et jusqu'à
ce qu'elle balance la vérité vous
connaissez donc les enquêtes de ba ba
oui maintenant il ya son cousin c'est
l'inspecteur la bavure
francesca antoniotti commettent une
erreur fatale mentir à l'inspecteur la
bavure c'est quand votre bonne
résolution mois marié nom aussi
attendait on sait pas si elle à la
personne déjà sauvé la personne banon
mais je suis vous êtes avec un corse a
beau pour moi vous connaissez ma vie la
suspecte bégaye pire encore elle nie
mais l'inspecteur la bavure et pugnace
je vous fais tes s'ébroue pas non juré
le chirurgien cracher sur matthieu
delormeau a dit la vérité
alors ne monte pas il savait ce qu'elle
faisait et musc est arrivé à capuche
ennahda l'inspecteur la bavure emploi
alors la menace une méthode bien connue
du groupe de loi alternative
départemental le clan francesca abou est
obligé de passer à table alors dit la
vérité
on est sur un petit truc à la corse
ouais les mecs et vous et de vous savez
ça chez kana avant même que vous ayez
gallas et le mec si c'est déjà les
applications la taloche arrivera dans sa
caisse
voilà une affaire rondement menée par
l'inspecteur la bavure
[Musique]
le tir on savait tout mais tu sais tout
je vois tout j'entends tout et je répète
tout attention merci c'est illégal
[Applaudissements]